bienvenue dans Quantum Computing en pratique, je suis ton hôte Olivia Lanes. La dernière fois, nous avons parcouru un exemple d'une
approche de Quantum Computing d'un problème d'optimisation connu sous le nom de Max cut en utilisant la formulation Cubo. Nous sommes allés
assez loin en profondeur, mais ce n'était qu'un exemple d'une approche. Aujourd'hui, nous allons aborder les applications à court terme
de manière plus large et développer notre intuition pour différents types de problèmes pour lesquels nous espérons trouver des solutions quantiques utiles
et voir quelques exemples récents de travaux importants réalisés dans notre communauté à une échelle d'utilité
précédemment, nous avons brièvement évoqué que tous les problèmes n'ont pas besoin de puissance de calcul supplémentaire
et notamment du Quantum Computing pour être résolus efficacement. Ce sont les problèmes que tu connais déjà le mieux :
l'arithmétique, le défilement sur les réseaux sociaux, peut-être jouer à Tetris, Doom ou d'autres jeux vidéo. Nous considérons globalement
ces problèmes comme faciles. D'un autre côté, il existe des problèmes très difficiles, comme trouver les facteurs premiers d'énormes
entiers, et c'est la base du chiffrement RSA, et c'est ce que l'algorithme de Shor a été conçu pour résoudre. Un autre
exemple est de trouver une solution dans un ensemble de données non trié. Cela peut théoriquement être résolu par l'algorithme quantique connu
sous le nom d'algorithme de Grover. Cependant, la plupart des experts s'accordent à dire que ces types d'algorithmes nécessiteront la
mise en œuvre de la correction d'erreurs, et nous n'en sommes pas encore là technologiquement parlant. Donc, en avançant dans cette
leçon et dans ton parcours d'apprentissage quantique, rappelle-toi que nous cherchons ce point optimal quelque part ici au milieu.
C'est un problème difficile à résoudre, mais c'est aussi ce qui le rend si passionnant. Une chose dont nous n'avons pas encore vraiment discuté,
c'est la théorie de la complexité computationnelle. L'une des raisons est qu'elle peut être un peu intimidante, et oui,
complexe. La théorie de la complexité computationnelle est le domaine de l'informatique qui vise à classer les problèmes computationnels
selon leur difficulté. Il existe une tonne de classes de complexité différentes en informatique classique, mais les plus
fondamentales sont les problèmes P. Ce sont des problèmes qui peuvent être résolus en temps polynomial et dont l'échelle augmente avec
l'augmentation du problème, ce qui signifie qu'ils sont faciles à résoudre. Le type de problème suivant, plus difficile, est les problèmes NP, qui
signifie polynomial non déterministe. Ce sont des problèmes dont les réponses peuvent être vérifiées en temps polynomial, mais pas
nécessairement résolus. Ensuite, il y a NP-complet, et là nous entrons dans les problèmes vraiment difficiles sans
solution polynomiale connue. C'est là que vivent des problèmes célèbres comme le problème du voyageur de commerce et même le jeu
Sudoku. Maintenant, lorsque le Quantum Computing a vu le jour, du moins en théorie, les gens ont consacré des efforts considérables à essayer de
déterminer quelle classe de problèmes ces nouveaux types d'ordinateurs seraient capables de résoudre efficacement. Une nouvelle classe de
problèmes a été inventée, appelée problèmes quantiques polynomiaux à erreur bornée, ou BQP en abrégé. Leur définition stricte est un peu
longue, mais c'est la classe de problèmes de décision solvables par un ordinateur quantique en temps polynomial avec une petite
chance d'erreur. Il y a une chance d'erreur parce que la mesure quantique est intrinsèquement aléatoire, mais l'erreur
peut être arbitrairement petite. Maintenant, toutes ces classes vivent dans une classe plus large que nous appelons PSPACE, et c'est là que
nous pensons que BQP se situe par rapport à tous les autres types de problèmes, mais il est très difficile de le prouver de manière définitive
mathématiquement. Tu remarqueras que les problèmes quantiques BQP ne se chevauchent pas nécessairement avec les problèmes NP-complets.
Cependant, tu as peut-être quand même vu des approches de Quantum Computing qui visent à résoudre des problèmes NP-complets. Pourquoi
serait-ce le cas ? Une idée fausse courante est qu'il n'y a aucun intérêt à explorer des solutions
à des problèmes comme le problème du voyageur de commerce et d'autres problèmes NP-complets pour un ordinateur quantique, ou pour tout problème pour lequel une
preuve mathématique d'accélération quantique n'a pas été trouvée. Cependant, ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas.
Trouver une preuve mathématique qu'un algorithme quantique est plus rapide que son équivalent classique est rare. Shor et
Grover sont deux des rares exemples où cela a été fait jusqu'à présent. Mais ça ne pose pas de problème. En fait,
les informaticiens n'ont même pas encore pu prouver que les classes P et NP sont différentes, même si toute intuition
nous dit qu'elles doivent l'être. De plus, comparer deux algorithmes et leur façon de passer à l'échelle examine souvent le pire cas
pour chacun. Il est tout à fait possible qu'en pratique, le pire cas ne soit pas ce que nous trouvons dans la vie réelle. Donc
ne désespérons pas. Nous introduisons plutôt l'idée de solutions heuristiques. Si tu es un
expérimentateur, tu connais et apprécies déjà ce type de solutions. Une heuristique est toute approche pour résoudre un
problème qui est pragmatique mais pas nécessairement optimale. Et c'est bien, parce que les solutions n'ont pas nécessairement besoin
d'être optimales pour être très utiles. Par exemple, pense à une application financière. Nous n'avons pas encore trouvé d'
accélération exponentielle pour la plupart des algorithmes financiers pour lesquels le quantique pourrait être utilisé. Mais ça n'a pas forcément d'importance. Nous n'avons pas besoin d'une solution optimale
en finance du moins, parce qu'une solution qui est même juste 1 % plus efficace pourrait équivaloir à des milliards de dollars
de bénéfices. Alors, comment savoir quels cas d'usage et problèmes pourraient être adaptés au Quantum Computing dès maintenant ? Et par là,
je veux dire qu'il y a des raisons sérieuses de croire que l'utilité quantique ou même l'avantage pourrait être trouvé soit maintenant, soit
dans un futur relativement proche. Peut-être qu'il est plus facile de nommer d'abord les choses que le problème ne devrait certainement pas avoir. Il
ne peut pas nécessiter un grand nombre de qubits. Nous n'avons pas encore de processeurs disposant de milliers à millions de qubits. C'est l'une des principales raisons
pour lesquelles l'algorithme de Shor et autres sont encore si loin. Les circuits ne peuvent pas non plus être incroyablement profonds. Il m'est vraiment difficile de
te dire exactement quelle profondeur de circuit ne fonctionnera pas, parce que cela dépend de tellement de facteurs. Mais en général, si ton
expérience nécessite une profondeur que tu n'as pas encore vue atteinte dans la littérature, tu risques d'avoir du fil à retordre. Et
enfin, tout type d'algorithme dont nous savons qu'il nécessitera la correction d'erreurs ne peut pas encore être réalisé. Ce que nous devrions rechercher, cependant, ce sont des expériences qui font
usage de la plupart des qubits disponibles sur un QPU donné. Nous avons également souligné l'
importance de l'atténuation et de la suppression des erreurs. Et enfin, il devrait y avoir une extension évidente vers de futures
applications qui seraient importantes pour la société et que nous pourrions envisager menant éventuellement à un avantage
quantique. Maintenant, parlons de quelques exemples de cas d'usage qui se répartissent en trois grandes catégories que nous avons
identifiées comme les plus susceptibles de donner des résultats favorables à court et moyen
terme. Le premier domaine est la simulation de la nature. Nous en avons déjà parlé. Il y a
tellement d'opportunités pour les ordinateurs quantiques d'améliorer les recherches effectuées au niveau moléculaire et atomique.
WEBVTT
Et la raison en est que les méthodes classiques actuelles sont limitées par des descriptions mathématiques fondamentalement inefficaces
des structures atomiques. Stocker et manipuler un état quantique nécessite une quantité exponentielle de ressources
sur un ordinateur classique, mais peut être réalisé efficacement sur un ordinateur quantique, et c'est ce qui fait de la simulation de matériaux
et de la modélisation chimique certains des domaines d'application les plus prometteurs. Plus précisément, cela pourrait conduire à des
développements dans la séquestration du dioxyde de carbone, les batteries alternatives ou l'invention de nouveaux médicaments. Certains
algorithmes particulièrement pertinents dans ce domaine sont le solveur variationnel quantique d'eigenstates VQE, utilisé pour
estimer certaines propriétés d'un matériau telles que l'équilibre ou les états d'énergie minimale. Un autre exemple est la
simulation dynamique temporelle TDS, cet algorithme est utilisé pour estimer les fonctions de réponse ou les propriétés spectrales des
matériaux. Je voulais aussi mentionner un nouvel arrivant, la diagonalisation quantique basée sur des échantillons, dont nous pensons que nous
entendrons beaucoup plus parler dans un futur proche. Le prochain domaine d'application est l'optimisation. L'optimisation est assez
omniprésente en informatique, comme tu peux l'imaginer, donc les cas d'usage sont assez nombreux et variés.
Cependant, quelques exemples dont nous entendons souvent parler sont l'optimisation de portefeuille en finance, la conception industrielle, et aussi
la distribution et la chaîne d'approvisionnement. L'algorithme le plus courant que tu entendras probablement en lien avec l'optimisation est celui que nous
avons déjà abordé en profondeur : l'algorithme d'optimisation quantique approchée, ou
QAOA. Enfin, un domaine qui a suscité beaucoup d'enthousiasme ces dernières années est l'apprentissage automatique quantique. Maintenant,
je pense qu'il est juste de dire qu'il semble que le QML ne va pas se produire aussi tôt que la simulation, en toute probabilité, mais néanmoins il y a
quelques algorithmes impressionnants sur lesquels les gens travaillent régulièrement, correspondant à des cas d'usage très importants.
Quelques-uns de ces cas d'usage possibles sont le traitement du langage naturel, l'analyse du trafic réseau et même la détection de fraude
dans les transactions financières. Les algorithmes pertinents dans ce domaine sont la machine à vecteurs de support quantique,
les réseaux de neurones quantiques et les réseaux génératifs antagonistes quantiques. Pour clarifier ces trois
groupes que nous venons de décrire sont de larges domaines d'application. Il convient également de noter que dans la communauté, il y a
aussi des avantages pour les groupes qui travaillent ensemble et qui se concentrent sur un sujet spécifique. IBM a lancé une initiative il n'y a pas si longtemps
appelée Les groupes de travail pour aider les collaborateurs à se rencontrer et à créer une synergie productive dans quatre domaines spécifiques :
la santé et les sciences de la vie, les matériaux et le HPC, la physique des hautes énergies et
l'optimisation. Voici nos groupes actuels et les entités impliquées dans ces efforts. Si tu veux en savoir plus sur
ce que font les groupes de travail, nous avons joint quatre de leurs livres blancs dans la description ci-dessous. Maintenant, comme je l'ai dit,
je pense que la meilleure chose à faire à ce stade du cours est de passer un peu de temps à explorer quels types de problèmes les gens travaillent sur à la pointe
de cette technologie et à développer notre intuition pour savoir quels types d'algorithmes vont fonctionner et comment
les appliquer. Et avant de commencer, je veux juste préciser très clairement que l'objectif principal ici n'est pas de comprendre chaque
détail des expériences. Ce type d'analyse peut être très intimidant même pour les experts si l'article est légèrement
en dehors de ton domaine d'expertise. L'objectif est simplement d'aider à développer une intuition pour les types de problèmes que les ordinateurs quantiques
gèrent bien et comment les aborder. Et si tu t'intéresses aux détails plus fins et que cela t'a inspiré quelques
idées, je t'encourage vraiment à aller lire les articles complets eux-mêmes. Les cas d'usage spécifiques et les
articles que nous allons examiner en détail sont les suivants. D'abord, nous explorerons un article qui traite de la
simulation de la dynamique des hadrons. Cela entre dans la catégorie de la physique des hautes énergies. Ensuite, nous examinerons un problème d'optimisation,
plus précisément l'optimisation quantique contre-adiabatique à champ biaisé. Et enfin, nous examinerons un autre
problème de simulation, mais cette fois en nous concentrant sur l'ARNm, une molécule cruciale pour le
développement de médicaments et de thérapies. Que tu sois familier ou non avec ces articles, ce n'est pas un problème. Nous allons
les parcourir tous. Ces trois articles importants s'attaquent à des problèmes de taille substantielle et montrent comment les ordinateurs quantiques
commencent à être utilisés comme une autre méthode d'investigation scientifique. Le premier est la simulation de la dynamique des hadrons,
et nous allons plonger dans un article du groupe de Martin Savage à l'Université de Washington intitulé Quantum
simulations of hadron Dynamics in the schwinger model using 112
qubits. Si tu n'es pas physicien des hautes énergies, tu es peut-être quand même familier avec le terme hadron, comme dans le
Grand collisionneur de hadrons ou LHC, qui est le gigantesque accélérateur de particules de 27 kilomètres de circonférence qui a rendu
possible l'observation finale du boson de Higgs. Un hadron est une particule composite subatomique composée d'autres petites
particules appelées quarks. Quelques exemples seraient les neutrons et les protons. Pour un peu de contexte, le LHC a été construit
pour permettre l'étude de la physique fondamentale et de ce qui arrive aux particules lorsqu'elles entrent en collision à des énergies super élevées
dans ce tube circulaire. Ce faisant, les scientifiques espèrent en apprendre davantage sur la façon dont l'Univers primitif est venu à l'existence.
Et comme je l'ai dit précédemment, il a également été utilisé pour trouver le boson, qui est une particule insaisissable responsable de la masse des
particules fondamentales. Maintenant, en principe, les interactions de ces particules pourraient être
simulées du début à la fin avec un ordinateur quantique suffisamment puissant. Nous n'en sommes pas encore tout à fait là, mais des progrès
sont réalisés. Maintenant, le modèle de Schwinger est un modèle simple utilisé pour simuler certaines de ces dynamiques et est devenu l'un des
modèles les plus populaires. Les détails du modèle ne sont pas super importants pour l'instant, mais pour les
curieux, c'est un modèle qui décrit le comportement des électrons et des positrons interagissant via des photons en 1 + 1 D,
ce qui signifie qu'il y a une dimension spatiale et le temps. Le modèle a beaucoup de similitudes avec la chromodynamique quantique,
qui décrit comment les quarks et les hadrons interagissent. Or, c'est extrêmement difficile à simuler, donc le
modèle de Schwinger est souvent utilisé comme modèle jouet pour explorer certains phénomènes qui sont en fait communs aux
deux. La façon dont nous allons procéder avec cet exemple et les autres exemples que j'ai sélectionnés est
de nous poser une série de questions. La première est : pourquoi avions-nous des raisons de croire que la simulation de ceci
sur un ordinateur quantique fonctionnerait du tout ? Dans ce cas, les électrons et les positrons du modèle de Schwinger ont un effet d'écrantage
causant la décroissance exponentielle des corrélations entre les fermions distants avec la séparation. Cela signifie qu'il y a
WEBVTT
moins d'interactions à longue portée d'un qubit d'un côté de la puce à l'autre de l'autre côté de la puce,
ce qui, nous le savons, est très sujet aux erreurs. Donc c'est vraiment bien pour le matériel dont nous disposons aujourd'hui. Ensuite,
ce sujet est-il même d'intérêt ? Eh bien, j'espère t'avoir déjà un peu convaincu que oui, la physique des hautes énergies est d'un grand
intérêt. Les gens étaient prêts à dépenser des milliards de dollars pour construire le LHC, et des milliers de scientifiques et
techniciens à travers le monde ont consacré leur vie à ce domaine. C'est dire à quel point c'est important. Mais le
modèle de Schwinger est simpliste et n'est pas conçu pour couvrir trois dimensions spatiales. Néanmoins, c'est un
modèle important car il fournit encore des tranches actuellement testables et une simplification utile d'une théorie complète.
Enfin, comment ce travail a-t-il été réalisé, ou quelle approche utiliseraient-ils s'ils cherchaient à continuer le travail dans des
expériences de type simulation ? VQE est l'une des approches les plus courantes, et la première étape est presque toujours la même :
préparer l'état fondamental. Dans ce cas, c'est un état de vide, et dans cette expérience, ils utilisent une nouvelle version du VQE appelée SC
adapt VQE pour préparer à la fois l'état fondamental et le paquet d'ondes du hadron au-dessus du vide. L'étape suivante est de
laisser les hadrons évoluer ou se propager dans le temps. Enfin, nous devons identifier les
observables que nous voulons détecter. Maintenant, si ces étapes te semblaient un peu familières, sauf la partie du paquet d'ondes du hadron,
c'est parce que ces étapes sont très similaires à ce que nous avons couvert dans l'exemple QAOA dans l'épisode précédent.
Espérons que tu commences à voir des schémas émerger ici. Les composants nécessaires pour VQE sont très similaires à QAOA.
Nous partons d'un état familier, ici l'état de vide, puis nous le laissons évoluer dans le temps avec une série d'hamiltoniens exponentialisés
divisés en morceaux gérables où n est le nombre de divisions. La seule grande différence ici
est que nous créons le paquet d'ondes du hadron centré dans notre circuit avant de commencer à le laisser évoluer. Alors, comment est-ce
fait ? Eh bien, l'état de vide est l'état fondamental et nous avons déjà plus ou moins couvert comment le mapper. Maintenant, la préparation du paquet d'ondes du hadron
est un peu différente. Sur ce vide, un hadron peut être excité en créant une paire fermion-antifermion sur des
sites adjacents. En préparant une superposition de ces hadrons à différents endroits, un paquet d'ondes arbitraire
peut être préparé. Les auteurs ont centré leur paquet d'ondes au milieu du circuit pour observer l'évolution
sans dépasser une frontière. Mais rappelle-toi que le nom du jeu lorsqu'on travaille avec des QPU bruités est de maintenir la
profondeur du circuit gérable. Pour ce faire, le protocole SC adapt VQE utilise la symétrie et les
hiérarchies dans les échelles de longueur pour déterminer des circuits quantiques à faible profondeur pour la préparation d'états. L'idée est que ceci
créera un ansatz avec un nombre plus petit de paramètres, ce qui équivaut à une profondeur plus faible. Plus de détails peuvent bien sûr
être trouvés dans l'article que nous n'avons pas le temps de couvrir ici. Alors assure-toi de le consulter. Regardons maintenant les résultats. Cette expérience a été réalisée sur
un appareil IBM Quantum Heron et a mis en œuvre quelques types différents d'atténuation et de suppression d'erreurs,
y compris une technique plus récente appelée renormalisation de décohérence des opérateurs, ainsi que le découplage dynamique, l'extrapolation
à bruit zéro et le poly twirling. Essayons maintenant d'interpréter les données. L'observable que nous allons en fait
mesurer pour observer la propagation du paquet d'ondes est ce qu'on appelle le condensat chiral, qui est un peu
abstrait mais c'est essentiellement une phase superfluide des hadrons. Maintenant, nous pouvons voir le paquet d'ondes centré ici sur les
sites désignés pour exécuter cette expérience, où la couleur correspond au condensat chiral. Le
côté gauche montre les résultats sans erreur du simulateur, tandis que le côté droit montre les résultats de l'ordinateur quantique IBM
Torino. Idéalement, ils seraient le miroir l'un de l'autre en raison de la symétrie. Tu peux donc voir qu'il y a
quelques imperfections. Maintenant, cet axe Y vertical correspond aux morceaux de temps que j'ai
mesurés plus tôt. Alors pourquoi ne pas prendre quelques coupes horizontales à travers les premier et dernier pas de temps des données pour voir
ce qui arrive au paquet d'ondes au temps t=1, ici en orange, correspondant à
cette coupe. Tu peux voir que le condensat chiral est étroit et localisé. Il correspond aussi vraiment bien à la
simulation effectuée pour comparaison. À t=14, cependant, il est beaucoup plus étalé et est moins
localisé. Peut-être que la comparaison avec le simulateur n'est pas aussi parfaite maintenant, mais tu peux encore voir clairement un très bon accord entre la théorie et les données,
ce qui est encourageant. En conclusion, c'est un exemple vraiment sympa du type de travail de simulation auquel tu ne penserais pas initialement
à appliquer les ordinateurs quantiques. Pourtant, en fait tu peux, et ça fonctionne. Ce n'est pas parfait, mais tu n'as pas à être un
expert en physique des particules pour voir que l'ordinateur quantique prédit avec précision la propagation vers l'extérieur du paquet d'ondes,
ce qui est exactement ce à quoi nous nous attendrions. J'espère que les travaux futurs dans ce domaine continueront et que les physiciens des hautes énergies
continueront à trouver des moyens d'intégrer le Quantum Computing dans leurs flux de travail. L'objectif est de résoudre des problèmes théoriques plus précisément et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas être traités classiquement, et d'utiliser des expériences pour accepter ou rejeter des théories dans l'espoir de découvrir de nouvelle
physique, de construire de meilleurs détecteurs et de parvenir à une meilleure compréhension de la nature à son niveau le plus fondamental.
Notre prochain exemple se concentre sur l'optimisation et sera une analyse approfondie d'un article intitulé biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization, réalisé par des membres de l'équipe Kipu Quantum à l'
Université du Pays Basque en Espagne. Nous allons commencer comme nous l'avons fait avant,
avec une série de définitions. La première est counter adiabatic, qui est un type d'évolution qui supprime les effets non adiabatiques
subis par un système, quel que soit la vitesse à laquelle ces processus se produisent. Rappelle-toi le théorème adiabatique du
dernier épisode. Tu dois généralement laisser un système évoluer très lentement si tu veux qu'il reste dans l'état fondamental.
C'est un gros problème car plus nous devons laisser les choses évoluer lentement, plus nous avons de temps pour que des erreurs
se produisent. Le counter adiabatic driving, souvent abrégé en CD, vise à combattre cela en
ajoutant des termes qui contrecarrent ces excitations indésirables. L'idée principale ici est d'accélérer toute l'expérience et
de réduire la profondeur du circuit quantique en supprimant les excitations qui pourraient conduire à des transitions
parasites. Parlons maintenant de ce qu'est un champ biaisé. D'autres algorithmes itératifs comme VQE intègrent des paramètres classiques dans
ces états et utilisent des optimiseurs classiques pour parcourir l'espace de paramètres multidimensionnel à la recherche de cet ensemble
qui donne une valeur d'espérance minimale pour un hamiltonien fixe. Dans ce cas, ils font plutôt varier l'hamiltonien à chaque
WEBVTT
fois en se déplaçant adiabatiquement d'un cas connu au cas d'intérêt. Mais puisqu'il n'y a pas de paramètres classiques
passés et pas de fonction d'onde variationnelle, comment mets-tu à jour ton état d'un passage à l'hamiltonien au suivant ? Eh bien,
ils ajoutent un champ de biais à l'hamiltonien. Quel que soit l'état d'énergie le plus bas de l'exécution précédente, ils ajoutent un terme dans
l'hamiltonien pour biaiser l'état en sa faveur. Alors pourquoi cette expérience est-elle
intéressante ? Eh bien, tout d'abord, c'est une nouvelle approche qui pourrait être appliquée plus généralement à d'autres problèmes d'optimisation.
Mais dans ce cas, ils l'ont appliquée à un problème de verre de spin d'Ising. Comme nous l'avons discuté précédemment, de nombreux problèmes d'optimisation combinatoire
peuvent être reformulés comme la résolution des états d'énergie faible des hamiltoniens d'Ising. Le modèle d'Ising
est une série de spins microscopiques distribués sur un réseau. Le modèle peut être utilisé pour décrire un verre de spin dans lequel
la magnétisation est désordonnée. En gros, les petits moments magnétiques sont orientés aléatoirement dans le réseau. Et
pourquoi pensions-nous que cela fonctionnerait ? Eh bien, nous avons déjà plus ou moins couvert comment nous combattons deux problèmes typiques trouvés dans les
algorithmes variationnels lorsque nous avons couvert les définitions de l'article. Mais pour résumer, l'algorithme qu'ils
proposent accélère l'évolution pour réduire la profondeur du circuit tout en supprimant les transitions non adiabatiques.
De plus, il ne repose sur aucune routine d'optimisation classique, ce qui peut être un problème menant à des
plateaux stériles et au blocage dans des minima locaux. Enfin, les auteurs veillent également à aligner les interactions dans le problème
hamiltonien avec la connectivité matérielle dans le vrai QPU, ce qui est toujours très important. Enfin, comment cela fonctionne-t-il ? Donc,
comme je l'ai dit, il n'y a pas d'optimiseurs classiques utilisés ici comme c'est souvent le cas dans les algorithmes quantiques itératifs.
Au contraire, en alimentant la solution de chaque itération dans l'entrée de la suivante, le champ biaisé digitisé
algorithme d'optimisation quantique raffine progressivement l'état fondamental, le rapprochant de plus en plus de l'
état final évolué. Et combiné avec des protocoles counter adiabatic, nous pouvons faire cela même avec des circuits quantiques
à faible profondeur qui devraient fonctionner sans problème sur du matériel bruité. Donc, lorsque l'expérience a été réalisée, les auteurs ont choisi d'exécuter l'
algorithme sur l'ordinateur quantique IBM à 127 qubits Brisbane. Ici, les auteurs ont montré
l'optimisation de l'algorithme pour une instance de verre de spin à voisins proches générée aléatoirement
sur plus de 100 qubits. Ils comparent les résultats de simulation idéaux de DCQ et BF DCQ
ainsi que le résultat expérimental, et ils montrent également un résultat d'un solveur classique appelé Gurobi comme référence. Maintenant,
avec seulement 10 itérations, BF DCQ fournit une amélioration drastique comparée à
DCQ. Bien que le résultat expérimental soit un peu différent du résultat idéal en raison du bruit, les performances sont quand même
meilleures que le DCQ idéal. Cela montre qu'il y a encore beaucoup d'excellents progrès réalisés en ce qui
concerne l'optimisation quantique, et de bons résultats sont rapportés sur plus de 100 qubits pour l'une des premières
fois. Pour finir, voici un article très intéressant explorant la prédiction de structure d'ARNm, de nos amis de
Moderna Pharmaceuticals, intitulé mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers. Pour commencer, si tu es comme moi et n'as pas suivi de cours de biologie depuis quelques années, tu peux te rappeler ce qu'est
l'ARNm. L'ARN messager est un type d'ARN impliqué dans la synthèse des protéines. Il
lit essentiellement les instructions données par l'ADN. La structure secondaire de l'ARNm est plus ou moins la façon dont la chaîne est pliée, et
le problème de prédiction de structure secondaire de l'ARN est le problème de trouver le repliement le plus stable de la séquence
des bases de nucléotides qui constituent l'ADN et l'ARN, à savoir C, G, U et A. Cette
image ici montre certaines des structures de repliement courantes trouvées dans l'ARNm. Chaque couleur mise en évidence ici montre une
structure secondaire différente. Mais les caractéristiques exactes de ce qui rend l'une de ces structures plus favorable qu'une
autre ne sont pas bien comprises. Tout ce que nous pouvons faire est de déterminer laquelle a l'énergie libre la plus basse par rapport à l'état
non replié, et c'est là qu'interviennent les ordinateurs quantiques. Alors pourquoi les structures secondaires d'ARNm
sont-elles importantes ? Eh bien, leur prédiction précise est en réalité cruciale non seulement pour comprendre l'ADN et nos gènes, mais aussi
pour concevoir des thérapeutiques à base d'ARN comme le vaccin contre la covid-19. Il y a des raisons de croire que l'approche dans
cet article fonctionnerait parce que c'est depuis longtemps connu comme étant un formidable problème d'optimisation pour les ordinateurs classiques,
en raison du vaste nombre de configurations possibles. Et pour certaines configurations, il est en fait connu qu'il s'agit d'un
problème NP-complet. Cependant, sur un ordinateur quantique, nous pouvons formuler la prédiction de structure secondaire comme un
problème d'optimisation binaire, quelque chose que nous savons gérer. De plus, il existe déjà dans la littérature des preuves
de prédiction précise d'ARN sur de petits dispositifs quantiques et des simulateurs quantiques. La question évidente est donc :
est-ce que cela fonctionnerait sur du matériel plus grand ? L'expérience est réalisée en utilisant quelque chose appelé le solveur variationnel quantique
à risque conditionnel, qui est une modification de l'algorithme VQE traditionnel et devrait
atteindre une meilleure convergence. Ce graphique montre la distribution des probabilités de mesure
des chaînes de bits échantillonnées avec les énergies correspondantes pour 42
nucléotides, instance à 80 qubits. Ici, les chaînes de bits symbolisent les appariements des
nucléotides. Cela illustre que la chaîne de bits à l'énergie la plus basse a une valeur d'énergie de -140, ce qui correspond à la chaîne de bits
à l'énergie la plus basse trouvée par le solveur classique comparatif. C'est donc super, et voici la structure repliée optimale
de cette chaîne de nucléotides basée sur la chaîne de bits à l'énergie la plus basse que le matériel a
trouvée. Et avec cela, nous avons atteint la conclusion de cet épisode. Mon objectif ici n'était pas de te submerger de
détails provenant de différents articles de recherche. Comme je l'ai dit, je voulais simplement te donner suffisamment de contexte pour comprendre à quoi
ressemble le travail de pointe dans ce domaine en ce moment. J'espère que cela va faire tourner les rouages dans
la tête de tout le monde et qu'en voyant comment d'autres abordent les problèmes, tu seras en mesure de faire des connexions et d'avoir la
confiance de tenter de nouvelles expériences quantiques que tu n'aurais peut-être pas osé avant. Et peut-être que certaines d'entre elles ne
fonctionneront pas, et c'est bien. C'est pourquoi c'est de la recherche. En avançant, rappelle-toi que les types de problèmes qui nous
intéressent peuvent être regroupés soit par méthodologie soit par sujet, et nous avons exposé ceux que nous croyons être
WEBVTT
les plus prometteurs à court terme. Rappelle-toi que le Quantum Computing n'est pas bon pour tout, et c'est vraiment juste un
témoignage de notre niveau de maîtrise de l'informatique classique. Ce n'est pas parce que tu penses pouvoir appliquer le Quantum Computing
à un problème que ça va donner des résultats intéressants. Malheureusement, tu dois tenir compte de la mise à l'échelle. La profondeur du circuit
est une arme à double tranchant. Nous avons besoin qu'elle soit considérablement grande pour faire un travail intéressant que les ordinateurs classiques
ne peuvent pas faire. Mais en ce moment, à cause du bruit matériel, on ne peut pas la pousser à des tailles énormes car la fidélité va
diminuer. Tout est question de trouver ce point optimal, en sachant que c'est une cible mouvante. Alors prends un peu de temps entre
maintenant et le prochain épisode pour réfléchir vraiment à quelques problèmes que tu as rencontrés et à comment tu pourrais vouloir les aborder avec ce que nous avons
appris jusqu'à présent. Sois créatif et ne te limite pas. Et si tu as des idées, même si tu penses qu'elles sont un
peu folles, fais-le moi savoir dans les commentaires ci-dessous. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine fois.